[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une de la presse
internationale on en parlait à l'instant
dans le journal de pauline godard
l'ukraine bien sûr avec l'accélération
des livraisons d'armes occidental à kiev
l'ukraine où les forces russes tentent
toujours de s'emparer de l'ensemble du
dombass l'otan et la russie s'accusent
mutuellement de chercheurs a provoqué
une troisième guerre mondiale le
quotidien italien il fatto quotidiano
fait notamment état ce matin de la
promesse du président américain joe
biden de livrer 20 milliards de dollars
d'équipements militaires offensif à kiev
une stratégie défendue dans le parisien
aujourd'hui en france par le chercheur
vincent touré qui fait partie de la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
qui explique que la diplomatie et tente
indexées aux résultats sur le terrain
les occidentaux sont obligés de soutenir
ces militairement l'ukraine pour aboutir
à des négociations pour renouer avec le
dialogue le quotidien l'humanité en
revanche est beaucoup plus sceptiques
selon lui les etats-unis écartent tout
danger de frappe nucléaire au détriment
de la recherche de négociations de paix
le journal cite le ministre la défense
américain qui dit s'être donné je le
cite pour objectif de voir la russie
affaiblie un degré tel qu'elle ne puisse
pas faire le même genre de choses que
l'invasion de l'ukraine un objectif qui
pourrait avoir pour conséquence la
poursuite de la guerre en ukraine
pendant plusieurs mois au moins d'après
l'humanité beaucoup de réactions
également hélène du côté de la presse
africaine tout autre sujet après
l'annoncé ce week end du chef de la
junte militaire en guinée qui a dit
vouloir rétablir la durée de la
transition à 39 mois avant de rendre le
pouvoir aux civils le 39 pas 36 ou 42
noms 39 c'est d'une précision d'horloger
ironise l'observateur paalga le
quotidien burkinabè se moque du
chronogramme de cette transition établi
par mamadou doumbouya le chef de la
junte qui a renversé le fath condé en
septembre 2021 trois ans et trois mois
un délai ni raisonnable ni acceptable
pour le journal qui compare ce délai aux
36 mois de transition exigé par paul
henri sandaogo damiba le chef de la
junte qui est au pouvoir au burkina faso
qui lui aurait au moins je cite
l'excusent d'être à la tête d'un pays
dont une bonne partie est sous l'emprise
des terroristes ou encore aux 24 mois de
transition demandé par assimiler aux
états le chef de la junte au pouvoir au
mali
trente neuf mois de transition en guinée
en rire ou en pleurer le site burkinabè
on voit qu'elle sert à exprimer son
inquiétude face au printemps de coup
d'état qui s'impose à une afrique de
l'ouest où les démocraties prend du
plomb dans l aile alors que ces
populations sont encore à la recherche
de solution à la faim et aux maladies et
vivent sur des terres dont la richesse
des sous sols ne profite qu'à d'autres
la multiplication des coups d'état en
afrique de l'ouest qui menace également
la liberté de la presse à la veille de
la journée mondiale de la liberté de la
presse le pays relève que la mission des
journalistes de porter la plume dans la
plaie leur obstination à vouloir
vérifier recouper et analyser
l'information avant de la rendre au
public n'est souvent pas du goût des
régimes kaki qui font preuve d'une
grande frilosité à chaque fois qu une
critique objective contrarie leurs
sombres desseins
manipulation du peuple le journal
burkinabè qui cite l exemple du mali
voisin où rfi et france 24 ont
définitivement été suspendu par les
autorités de transition met également en
garde le président burkinabè dany bad as
me bats dans ce pays de norbert zongo le
journaliste burkinabè qui fut assassiné
en 1998 on préfère mourir aux portes de
la liberté que de pourrir dans les
enfers de la servitude la presse à
l'épreuve du pouvoir kaki dans ce pays
en france les traditionnelles
manifestations du 1er mai en prière
hélène dimanche un tour très politique
une semaine tout juste après la victoire
d'emmanuel macron à la présidentielle et
les syndicats français préviennent
makrouds financial times évoque des
rassemblements dominée par les
préoccupations concernant le pouvoir
d'achat les prix de l'énergie et la
réforme des retraites qui annonce
emmanuel macron confrontée à son premier
grand défi de son second quinquennat
avec les législatives
du mois prochain des élections que la
gauche au sein cherche à aborder dans
l'unité le monde annonce que le conseil
fédéral d'europe écologie les verts a
voté largement hier le texte conclu avec
la france un souvenir de jean luc
mélenchon les écologistes et les
insoumis formant désormais pauline la
nouvelle union populaire écologiste et
sociale les deux formations espèrent
désormais ouvrir la voie à d'autres
union avec le parti communiste et le
parti socialiste dont le patron olivier
faure a accepté de négocier avec jean
luc mélenchon provoquant la colère d'une
partie de son propre camp qui craint de
se dissoudre dans la france insoumise
est ce la fin du ps s'interroge le
parisien qui voit les socialistes en
sursis le parisien pauline ou le dessin
dans son antre des socialistes en train
de se déchirer pas question de négocier
avec les insoumis si on le doit
maintenant on a deux gauches dit
réconciliables au sein même du ps la
perspective d'une union d'une union de
la gauche dominée par jean luc mélenchon
qui donne des sueurs froides à l'opinion
le journal prédit déjà
l'inexorable soumission de la gauche aux
patrons des instruments voilà pour cette
une de l'opinion se dit hélène tout à
l'heure avec un revoir des noctambules
parisiens s'en est allé réginal
zylberberg dit régine est morte hier à
l'âge de 92 ans une éclipse de plumes
titre joliment libération en référence
bien sûr à la célèbre chanson mon truc
en plumes les amateurs de beau à dont je
suis je le confesse sont orphelins bel
hommage également ce matin du journal
suisse le temps emporté par la nuit
titre ultime pour celle que françoise
sagan avait surnommée la reine noire ni
blanche vous êtes beau à hélène moi
j'étais les petits papiers quelle belle
chanson merci beaucoup et l'aisne